- Is it a bad sign that
I've been doing this
for 20 seconds and I'm
already out of breath?
(80s electronic music)
- I love the '80s.
I was a kid in the 80s.
- I don't care what decade we're in,
I'm an out of shape piece of shit.
- I'm worried I won't be able to keep up.
- I might flash my nutsack at you.
- Richard Simmons is my boy.
We go way back.
- Alright, so we're doing
like a Thriller thing.
- I love this.
- This is just like a music video.
- Egyptian arms. I never
hear that in CrossFit.
- Is that racist?
- Maybe.
- What am I doing?
- I keep doing the wrong legs!
(laughing) I'm sorry
but who are the people
in this video and why are
the dressed for the office?
- I kind of like this, though,
'cause it's not exercise,
it's just like bar mitzvah dance moves.
- If I could describe my fitness,
it would be medium fit grandma.
- This woman's body is sick.
- She has a thigh gap.
- Put the ball between your legs.
- Oh, all these other grannies are coming!
- This is kinky shit.
- If I can look these grannies
by doing this, I'm all for it.
- My ball is dropping. (laughs)
- I sure do feel emasculated.
- Man, this is working
my legs in a weird way.
- I feel like she's judging me.
- If you're a grandma that can hold
a ball between your legs,
you're probably already
in good shape for a grandma.
- (laughs)
- What? (laughs)
- I hate this. I hate this.
- What is this an exercise for?
- Oh, she's singing along.
This woman is multi-talented.
- It's kind of fun.
- Oh, what? This is crazy!
- Oh, I got it.
They're doing bad.
- (laughing) One of them lost their ball.
- Oh, that granny (beep) up.
- Alright, they are a little more nimble
than you give them credit for.
- This is the one that might kill me.
- I got the hang of this.
I was born in the 80s, damn it.
- Okay, wait. Alright, start it over.
- Anyone that can rock
that leotard, hot damn!
- What a bizzare exercise.
- This is not that different
from what I do now.
- Getting my pelvis ready for child birth.
- Yes! Yes! Yes!
- Estrogen! Estrogen! Estrogen!
- I feel empowered.
- Why are we doing this?
- I feel this one.
- It's really escalated!
- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8!
- This is more fun guys!
- It reminds me of my dancing days.
- I like doing the momentum.
- I don't get this! (laughs)
- What?
- It's going too fast.
I don't know what you're doing.
Explain the move to me!
- I'm not good at this.
- I can't do anything that
involves two body parts at once!
- The last guy, he just
was like, "Alright!"
He's got it. That guy got that.
- Holy shit.
- That was lots of fun.
- I really want this
tape. I'm not kidding.
- It's a lot sillier
than exercise today is.
- I'd rather just run.
- I like the community aspect,
like it's just people in a room.
- These women have presence.
- I get to keep this, though, right?
- I wish this was all you
needed to do to get a six pack,
because the world would be a better place.
I'd love to make the
switch from actual weights
and ab core exercises to just going,
"Whoo! Think about dinner, ladies!"